hello and welcome to this video against
redox ok I've not played this person
before ever new opponent yes the night
is moving in L shapes yeah maybe you
just got a phone call or something so it
cleans gambit classical net bd7 ok push
it before here not aware of this
particular line ok I think III should be
ok just play normal development k Quincy
to a look see one mmm not sure it is a
big issue here yeah it's getting is
getting very quick play against mine and
see 39 I think I'll just play on good
development
interesting yeah probably just eating
some general i'm happy with any opening
of the position s I'm ahead on the head
with development I had would be very
very risky to take i have c takes 25
with Quincy eight at the end also that
looks pretty terrible don't think you
can take on c3m cd5 Quincy aid hmm ok
habit what is this movie I cannot cancel
I mean age seven is hanging and II take
screen c8 is over yeah Quincy 80 is also
winning I'm winning lots of material it
says some tricks are there any tricks I
don't see it check check so I'm a piece
up the only thing is that you might have
some some trickery the rook is currently
not having many squares okay
hmm Roxy one maybe for Rupe to see seven
he's not threatening yet to trap the
rook well I don't like so much is that I
have a couple of unprotected pieces him
it can be tricky but I have Bishop
everyone to cover against back rank
things which is which is good so what
now Luke c7 is going 97 it looks pretty
bad rook c8 done I don't see a reply
check 97's only moves down why is it
taking so long for those false moves
because it is not a false move from here
okay I didn't see that this move as
possible okay anyway how to do this now
just look look g 7i guess
I guess it should be okay mmm I didn't
see that move I'm at night if five might
be good here right 95 takes Bishop g5
check that looks rather dangerous but
not sure if it is decisive
hmm you should age six maybe efore guess
seven I can take on d3 yeah that's so
kind of dangerous it's amazing that
night xe5 does not seem to win but I
don't get it to work ok so here I wanted
to play rook f7 which is completely
completely bogus plate that really badly
this is far more complicated than it
should have been added I'm not quite
sure about its objective merits maybe
black is fine yeah I don't know check
now okay here should be if she should be
ok stopping the deep worn so check ok
what now how do I get just get back here
probably and time learning make sure
that the deep oil is not going anywhere
did you look the one then I'm just
taking it and let's not even so clear
I'm not doing this well d to hook the
one Queen 846 check through just about
win but
very bad technical play by me but I
think it's talk it's still just for just
win check
check check check check okay and it was
shaky it looked like a very shaky
conversion my maybe he had something
ok ok
you
yeah okay he's got lots of time on his
hands now probably i don't know maybe
there was nothing but i felt like i
should have thumb should have them
played this in a more convincing way
yeah i don't really know what the point
of this is i have 1 minute 30 left why
not just resign start a new game you
cannot start a new game while a game is
still running you on the ISIS you cannot
play two games at the same time just a
very childish behavior in some way
yeah okay 20 what's this he really
disconnected in some way or what no what
black forfeits on time no with some kind
of weird d'Alene okay anyway um yeah it
should have been a much purer affair I
mean here black is in trouble and he has
to move this Bishop back in order to
avoid material loss but this is of
course a pretty bad position as my
development is so much stronger
something something like this is pretty
bad he cannot castle he lost some day
lots of time with 94 and all this
business yeah and him that it's very
dangerous he could have played this
though something like this this is again
it's very dangerous but check funny
funny line oops sorry teens takes takes
takes takes rook f91 push up chicks
Queenie towards the engine line it's
pretty nice threatening mate where it's
a disaster yeah you should develop from
time to time check chan yeah but still I
think either should have been a much
clearer win here this this cannot be bad
really Janice this Butchie 75 and no
bishop d 2 is given by the comp Nanak
makes an awful lot since gaining a
temple yeah that was very good actually
i gaining a temple you cannot take
because of age and this asks black and
very proud difficult to answer question
of thing and here yeah yeah i can take
this is pretty
need threatening to win everything here
yeah it would have been much much
clearer but this is also winning right
yeah yeah it is winning hey I'm getting
getting back my my rooks and can
coordinate and I didn't screw it up chan
just wasn't the most oh check check
forceful way of doing things but it was
always even after year played the
opening so badly ok well thanks for
watching